how would your kid how does he too two
years old yes yes how's it is it hard to
like you know juggle being a superstar
rapper and being a mom of a two-year-old
yes it is hard because I'll be missing
him sometimes I got to be away from him
for a couple days at a time
and then I'll see him a week week at a
time two weeks at a time who's helping
with the kid grandma Yeah the grannies
and my baby daddy used to help before he
got locked up I have help baby daddy's
incarcerated yeah are you guys uh
cordial yeah we cool as [__] that's my
[__] like we still cool is he like uh
like are you waiting for him to get out
yeah yeah when he get out like you're
talking about for us to be together yeah
no when he like before he got locked up
he was a hoe and was talking to other
people but he still would come spend the
night at my house we still is cool right
we wasn't [__] enough we just was
real cool you guys are friends yeah me
and my baby daddy friends before
anything and she like have any idea how
big you are right now he know now and
he's shocked because he see he said
people in jail be singing all my songs
and you know it's people in jail with
phones yo what imagine a bunch of men in
jail singing pound town they do big paws
they do though he said they mean yo
imagine a bunch of grown-ass men talking
about time I don't want to hear that in
jail and they play it on the radio
though so he gonna hear it on already
it'd be on the radio in jail he don't
that would be the soundtrack I don't
want in a Men's prison he says it's the
gay boy in there he said the boy walking
around pound town just left pound town
and he's probably actually just left
pound town in the shower he said he
acting like he said he rapping like me
he said he trying to change his voice to
sound like how I talk wow he's so funny
that's so funny and then when I was on
the phone with him we was on the phone
he was already telling me about it I
started hearing him in the background I
said is that him and he started laughing
he was like yeah he just be in his cell
just hollering my lyrics all day that's
so funny is that a cellmate no [__] no I
don't know you know people no he said
he'd be hollering from all the way down
the hall pound town so like that's
that's gonna be pretty dope to be your
baby daddy yeah yeah he said no he don't
he don't they know he my baby daddy now
because they watching all my old videos
and they see who he is he said they
coming up to him in jail saying is you
is you sexy red baby like and he but he
not oh yeah this is my baby mama he
don't be he not like that does your son
is he like in the like you know my kids
are young and they're on YouTube a lot
no my son he he don't know about YouTube
he too well he'll be on YouTube he's
badass he'd be watching kids you sit
down yeah like the kids like some of
those kids channels are crazy yeah
Ryan's toy review there's this Asian kid
who just opens toys and like makes
millions and millions of dollars
like just anything they're literally bad
toys no good choice uh like you know
like uh I think he'd be having sex no no
anything no no it's a little kid and he
just reviews toys with his dad they're
so cute and the [__] oh man Chucky can
do something like that oh you would go
crazy
if you start a YouTube channel doing
that or a tick tock you're [__] paid
oh you think so just open it toys yeah
cause he get toys all day just open them
and review them and people gonna be
wanting to see him soon and you just be
yourself for real yes cause when we be
opening them my son be excited he'd be
like
I'd be like yeah you got your toys I'm
like how we finna put this [__] together
like how the [__] are we feeling oh
that's going viral we'll be sitting
there putting the [__] together millions
of views and he'd be so excited he'd be
excited like yeah oh you're going you're
going up with that all right say number
yeah yeah yeah shout out to your kid
yeah you're you're yeah hey lud is she
he's so small he loves new [__] every
time you come home you bring him some
new [__] like I've been gone two or
three days yeah I got you you know I do
of course I think about him all day so
while I'm out if I'm getting myself some
clothes I'll be like hold on they got
kids in here any store I got so if they
got kids [__] I'm shopping for myself
are you gonna do anything for yourself
for Mother's Day or for your mom I'm not
really celebrating it for real I don't
know like do you like because mom's been
helping out you you know maybe taking a
spa day or something of course I'm gonna
turn her up yeah of course yeah that's a
good idea too I should plan a spa day
but I gotta see if we're gonna keep the
[__] kids you say you don't want your
kid growing up in St Louis you plan on
leaving
um yeah I do I ain't gonna because at
first I was gonna stay but they'd be
hating too bad and I ain't know it was
gonna get like how it is because I'm
thinking I could get real big but this
one I wasn't as big as I am now I think
I get real big and stay where I'm at
right but I see I can't I wasn't gonna
be able to do that because now I'm where
I you know I'm saying I'm getting bigger
and I see what's going on yeah they say
like you get more hate from where you're
from than anywhere else you do I do when
I say they be hating so bad I mean it's
crazy I'll be like that like I don't
know many people I would have stayed
like I mean obviously Atlanta you'd want
to stay in Atlanta if you're from
Atlanta because it's Atlanta but I feel
like everybody else like from like
random cities like I don't know anybody
from Baton Rouge the state in Baton
Rouge yeah type [__] I give it two
things in Atlanta Fredo bangs in Miami
like yeah yeah I get what you're saying
yeah [__] always yeah move out
because it's where you from they be
heading the most because they'd be
feeling like how come it ain't them how
come her right so that is how it goes
yeah so they're not gonna support this
because you only make pound town okay
doing this [__] that's why they mad
cause they like she steady this [__]
steady doing going viral doing this this
I don't know I just always go borrow
I'll just be doing some